[Musique]
il a constaté maintenir je m'appelle
constantin matveïev
et je suis directeur de la troupe du
ballet de moscou g enseignant en danse
classique
j'estime que le ballet russe classique
est le meilleur au monde je m'appelle
hayat onesi gym à r je suis venue en
russie à danse et le ballet russe
quelqu'un en vie mais pointe dit les
laisser je m'appelle cristina rios china
je suis soliste du ballet de moscou je
m'appelle arkham ignatyev je suis
chorégraphe du ballet de moscou je suis
passionné par la chorégraphie moderne
je m'appelle dimitri proulx sackhoff je
danse les rôles principaux du ballet de
moscou nous avons renoncé au ballet
classique dans notre théâtre
elles n'ont pas besoin de moi parce que
j'enseigne la danse classique
d'autres auraient allez-y
attention
ne vous pressez par en acheter un autre
théâtre met l'accent sur la danse
moderne et a commencé à remplacer son
répertoire classique sa part du moderne
à l'étranger on attend d'abord des
danseurs russes qu'ils fassent de la
danse classique mais j'ai vu des gens
qui ne comprenaient pas comment on
pouvait de nos jours se consacrer à cet
art d'une autre époque
vous savez ce que vous faites une
nouvelle fois avec hayato vous faites
ces petits mouvements comme ça ce n'est
pas vraiment confortable je sais mais
vous vous souvenez fait une extension
comme ça 1er 2e non pas vous vous de la
dhimma iatos où devait au moins faire ce
pas avec une extension et revenir après
parce que sinon c'est trop il est sans
doute t32 parler ainsi mais nous ne
sommes pas la meilleure troupe pour le
répertoire classique selon moi nous
avons certes des danseurs mais il est
plus facile d'assister un bon classique
dans les grands théâtres
nous n'avons pas de soliste aussi fort
qu'ils soient vraiment passionné par
gisèle ou quelque chose dans georges
quand j'ai entendu ce que disait artyom
et j'étais très en colère parce que je
n'étais pas du tout d'accord avec ces
propos à mon avis ils avaient tort nous
avons de très bons artistes des solistes
qui travaille maintenant dans de grands
théâtres au concours quatre oies le
choix au bolchoï stanislavski au ballet
du kremlin
nous avons monté de magnifiques
spectacles classiques bien
[Musique]
jake allen maintenant le genou en eau
fléchi
[Musique]
10 à voter à dimitri et ça tu t'es juste
levé mais la variation n'était pas
encore terminée elle est terminée une
fois que tu es derrière les coulisses
après la révérence d'accord et toi tu
t'es levé un peu comme dans une salle
d'entraînement
n'est ce pas j'ai un trop plein
d'émotions là je sais pourquoi tu as
trop d'émotions voilà il a entendu
quelque chose et maintenant ils
débordent d'émotion hier soir bien sûr
je comprenais ces réactions parce que
c'était absolument faux dix mois dimitri
lui même avait remporté le concours
international de perm que le missile
avait gagné la médaille d'argent d'un
concours international en corée ces
artistes sélectionnés les artistes pour
notre théâtre relève de ma
responsabilité
ali je peux dire qu'ils ont un très bon
niveau pour le répertoire classique très
bien très bien encore plus tendue encore
à davao faisons une pause maintenant je
dois dire que j'avais envie de crâne et
un peu après cette interview avec le
pseudo enseignants estime waheed ne
finit pas ça après sa phrase concernant
le niveau peu élevé de classiques mais
dès cette séquence là et encore on est
gentil mais je comprends pas comment on
peut dire des choses pareilles je me
suis mis en colère parce qu'il a tenu
ces propos devant ce dont il parlait
ouvertement
quand j'ai commencé la répétition
j'étais souvent distrait par ce que j'y
pensais je ne pouvais pas croire à cette
insolence croire que des gens sont
capables de s'exprimer de la sorte
j'ai demandé à faire une pause car
j'avais besoin de me calmer de me
ressaisir pour continuer la répétition
notre théâtre se monter n'importe quelle
production de danse classique
c'est ça le niveau du ballet russe
dimitry pro sackhoff hayato nishima ce
sont des artistes de ballet de très bon
niveau
hayato et japonais
un japonais qui est venu dans le pays où
existent
le meilleur ballet du monde n'est ce pas
hayato c'est ça aux minières fouilles
poignet j'ai au japon mon propre projet
qui est lié au ballet classique
constantin m'encourage à entretenir la
forme classique quoi c'était ce que
formant immune nécessaires à ce projet
rihanna shoprite très bien c'est ce que
nous appelons la japonaise regardez
c'est un bon mouvement un saut japonais
un saut japonais ils pensent que pelé
quête à cape town et un seau japonais
c'est ce que j'ai dansé lors de la
première étape du concours arabesques
thackwell c'est un saut avec un grand
écart non pas tout mou dans l'appel la
japonaise en russie je ne sais pas
pourquoi
voilà c'est très bien le théâtre a cessé
de mettre en scène des ballets
classiques ou pour être plus précis les
ballets classiques ont été négligés à
coke et rien n'allait plus comme avant
une fois tous les ballets classiques
suspendu voici ce que j'ai compris que
j'aurais du mal à me trouver une place
dans ce théâtre aujourd'hui sernatur ah
non je suis en retard
j'espère qu'il est encore temps bonjour
balle et moscou envisagent des digues ne
sait pas où et dimitri je n'arrive pas à
joindre pour la répétition regarde s'il
est là où il n'est pas dans le vestiaire
nom du monde dimitri était en retard
pour la répétition et cela ne lui était
jamais arrivé
je n'arrivais pas à le joindre je ne
comprenais pas les choses alors j'ai dû
commencer la répétition sans solis
attention les artistes du ballet de
moscou les participants du spectacle et
ross veuillez entrer sur scène je répète
ce ballet de moscou vous êtes invités à
venir sur scène bonjour
ghannouchi a bien sûr que j'étais
nerveux car la première répétition sur
la nouvelle scène commencé sans soliste
et ce d'autant plus que j'étais
responsable des artistes plus 10 mythes
raymond lévesque
je suis responsable de lui
personnellement et pas seulement en tant
que directeur loubat c'était trop sombre
tu te sofia après au moment du final
alors j'en rajoute oui en tout cas une
fois que leur musique terminé j'allume
oui oui je vois difficile et bien faute
d'avoir notre propre scène nous sautons
tout le temps d'un théâtre à l'autre
c'est ça le truc
nous avons à nous adapter soit nous
n'avons pas de matériel soit nous
n'avons pas le temps c'est à dire que
lorsque nous arrivons dans un théâtre
nous devons travailler sur l'ensemble du
spectacle ont l'espace d'une journée
bonjour ce jour là notre soliste dimitri
pour ça qu offre est arrivée en retard
ce qui nous a rendu encore un peu plus
nerveux et inquiet bonjour j'étais en
retard pour la répétition mais
heureusement pas pour le spectacle car
les embouteillages étaient énormes
je n'avais pas l'intention de décevoir
ni constantin ni les artistes ni
personne mitri va si vite c'est bien que
dimitri et russie à venir pour la
répétition
d'accord il était en retard gd tout de
même venu je me suis calmé un peu
je n'avais pas le temps de l'engueuler
on a commencé à se mettre au travail
[Musique]
je crois que les spectacles de notre
théâtre sont parmi les meilleurs de la
danse moderne en russie nous sommes
lauréat du prix masque d'or dans la
catégorie danse moderne
si nous avons renoncé au ballet
classique dans notre théâtre
d'abord parce que la niche de la danse
moderne n'était pas occupé il ya des
théâtres qui font un peu de classique
qui est un peu de danse moderne
nous avons choisi le domaine de la danse
moderne parce qu'il est plus
progressiste je dirais pas gâcher ou
dangereux
ça y est bêta je rêve de danse et
giselle depuis que je suis tout petit
test
c'était mon rêve d'enfant et maintenant
je travaille ici je comprends qu ici au
ballet de moscou est mon rêve de danse
et giselle ne se réalisera peut-être pas
car je vais déjà dans une direction un
peu différente
c'est un peu triste en fait les fiv
n'est pas dû mais pointe
je ne les trouve pas non pas oublier le
plus important où les âges laisser ses
new skies tania tu ne les as pas vu non
plus j'ai des choses je peux les mettre
pour danser je rigolais nerveusement car
j'ai perdu mes points je me suis rendu
compte que je ne pourrais pas danser ce
spectacle si nous allons de théâtre en
théâtre est comme ça il arrive qu'on
perde des choses ah ben voilà je les
avais laissés
c'est un début d'alzheimer
ça ne m'arrive pas souvent mais ça
arrive je vais sur scène je n'étais pas
censée danser ce spectacle mais l'une
des filles celle qui jouait le rôle
principal s'est blessé et j'ai dû me
préparer pour le masque d'or au bolchoï
oui étape je danse dans ce spectacle
depuis le choc concernant les classiques
à l'université déjà je m'étais rendu
compte que ce n'était pas mon truc
nice n'était pas mon point fort on peut
dire que je suis un admirateur et un
connaisseur de la chorégraphie moderne
nos balais ne sont pas ceux qu'on trouve
de pire dans la danse contemporaine je
te mange mon but
nos rations mois quand concerne 7e comme
il le dit lui-même et amateurs de
chorégraphies modernes où il est
chorégraphe
il met en scène des balais je pense que
les directeurs de théâtres et les
chorégraphes sont partisans et partisans
à moi ce sont les artistes du ballet
classique et partisans sont ceux qui ont
appris au monde occidental à danser mais
celle qui ont enseigné le ballet jazz
maintenant c'est la répétition sans moi
rien
ils ont bien sûr d'autres enseignants
ils n'ont pas besoin de moi maintenant
je suis un enseignant classique
bien sûr je pourrais bien apporter je
peux quelques corrections
mais le ministre confie j'ai remarqué
que constantin était un peu distant
pendant la répétition et comment tout
comme s'il ne participait pas au
processus
peut-être que ce n'est pas son truc du
bien il n'était pas sûr de lui quand il
s'agit de chorégraphies modernes
je ne sais pas faire à vrai dire il a
été un danseur classique
il est pour bonne chance merci tu as
chanté un bon merci on commence dans une
minute
ce jour là nous avons montré de balai
coup minos et eros il s'agit d'une mise
en scène d'un des meilleurs chorégraphes
de pays bas voire d'europe
ce sont des adaptations des mythes de
l'antiquité grecque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
je dansais dans le minotaure dans le
ballet luminos cac hector là il n'y
avait pas de sauts de rotation ou
d'autres éléments techniques difficiles
mais il fallait transmettre l'image du
minotaure j'avais à créer l'ambiance
nécessaire pour faire en sorte que le
spectateur ressente cette énergie
c'était ça je crois le plus difficile
[Musique]
au début les spectateurs sont là à ne
pas comprendre ce qu'il se passe les
gens viennent voir le ballet en
s'imaginant de grands décors de beaux
costumes
mais il se retrouve face à du
minimalisme le public se demande aussi
pourquoi on ne danse pas en justaucorps
pourquoi on ne fait pas de grands shows
ou d'autres choses de ce genre
au lieu de ça on rampe ont fait d'autres
choses
basma les cornes comment les cornes
pointées jusqu'ici dans presque toutes
les chorégraphies modernes les
mouvements sont bien moins diversifiés
que ce que les artistes du ballet
peuvent faire c'est si avant on était
censés voler maintenant on leur demande
de ramper
m
[Musique]
rochât se dit désormais dimitri danse
bien mais son potentiel n'est pas
vraiment utilisé à 100 % il s'agit d'une
partie d'une toute petite partie de ses
capacités j'espère en fait qu'il
rencontrera dans sa vie un grand maître
de ballet jeu ça lui permettra de se
réaliser en tant que danseur
[Musique]
je n'étais pas prêt à renoncer à la
danse classique bien sûr je triais
installe colère parce que j avais
consacré tant d'années je suis encore
jeune hier j'aime beaucoup mon travail
et je veux continuer à m'améliorer
[Musique]
à
en fait nous savons tous dans quel genre
de théâtre nous sommes arrivés c'est
pourquoi nous devons accepter certaines
choses
alors oui je voudrais danser les
classiques je pourrais travailler au
théâtre stanislavski par exemple mais je
comprends que cela aurait un impact sur
ma famille que je devrais faire des
tournées rester au théâtre jusqu'à 22h à
prendre tout le répertoire dsk ont chois
ton cas cette année mais je vais me
marier et cela ne m'arrange pas du tout
de faire des tournées liaison castres au
cas où j'ai dit que je suis plus un
soldat
[Musique]
j'aimerais bien que christine se réalise
en tant que danseuse classique
il a tout ce qu'il faut pour cela que ce
serait regrettable que christina décide
de ne plus bas brinjal à construire
il y avait des rumeurs au théâtre selon
lesquelles constantin pourrait nous
quitter et on gagne à snam inquiéter car
cela pouvait affecter ma situation au
ceat sauf cet été à temps parce
qu'habituellement c'est lui qui me
soutenaient non plus n'est pas non il ya
routine mais j'espérais vraiment qu'il
ne quitterait pas qu il changerait
d'avis girouette
merci il ya une histoire pavés je ne
pouvais pas croire que constantin
quitterait le ballet de moscou
ce qu il ya à dire j'espérais qu'il
changerait d'avis
moi même j'avais encore des doutes parce
que les gens venaient souvent me
demander de montrer comment faire tel ou
tel mouvement au logo de les gènes
l'idée de pouvoir encore aider quelqu'un
me retenais ici on chantait déjà
notre deuxième spectacle c'était eros
c'est aussi un ballet court basé sur la
mythologie la chorégraphie avait ses
difficultés techniques mais
techniquement ce n'était pas aussi
épuisant qu'un spectacle classique un
accord et ses spectacles
[Musique]
je savais que tous les artistes ne
seraient pas satisfaits de ce spectacle
mais tous les chemins sont ouverts il y
à un embarras de choix
on peut danser les classiques on peut
danser tout ce qu'on veut ou alors il
suffit de s'en aller personne ne vous
retient pour demain je sais pas trop si
on prenait une variation quelconque
après le classique
puis gilles et après d'accord on peut
reprendre oui demain
et puis on pourra répéter encore celle
ci las il vide pour que cela descendre
un peu plus dans les jambes ouvre les
coulisses pendant le spectacle
nous étions tellement paix par notre
discussion sur la répétition du
lendemain j'ai failli rater les séries
spectacle la salle était presque plein
les spectateurs viennent à nos
spectacles
j'étais content après le spectacle
constantin est passé à côté de moi comme
s'il ne m'avait pas remarqué normalement
nous nous félicitons après spectacle
quelques remarques quelques commentaires
aux artistes lestang à cette fois
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon travail les garçons merci choc
d'autres avant le spectacle j'hésitais
encore entre partir et rester au théâtre
non mais quand il a touché à sa fin
il ya des scènes j'avais déjà pris ma
décision de chaud j'ai encore oublié les
épingles comme tu n'es pas une femme
bah ouais j'ai décidé d'entraîner
dimitri pour un concours international à
varna on avait envie de replonger dans
ce dont nous avions été privés ces
derniers temps les deux shows mais bon
je sais être en bonne forme physique à
nous manquer maintenant c'est ali
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'it
bon travail parce qu un chant théâtre
nous n'avons pas de costume pour cela
dans notre théâtre nous avons dû nous
adresser à un atelier qui fait des
costumes a lâché 4 cd ça je devais me
faire moi même un costume à mes propres
frais un costume écossais traditionnel
sapin en jupe
non pas vraiment je me sens différent je
suis un homme je ne porte jamais ça
c'est nouveau pour moi et en plus je
vais devoir danser avec c'est pourquoi
j'ai mis pour répéter pour m'habituer
bon allez on y va dimitri est sans aucun
doute l'un des meilleurs danseurs
il ya dix mois je ne dirais pas que
c'est la star numéro un mais c'est
vraiment un bon danseur adam sur de très
haut niveau et en plus il est jeune il
doit développer ses qualités il peut
encore se développer et devenir un très
bon danseur
et
un peu plus d'impulsivité tu voulais
faire une dernière pirouette mais tu as
changé d'avis ce qui me manque c'est le
jeu de jambes oui probablement
j'étais trop détendu
il ya ni wars que dimitri serait
remarquée ne faisait aucun doute
même s'il ne gagnait pas le concours est
close watch it et on en entendrait
parler du ballet moscou où il travaille
tu as bien travaillé aujourd'hui
merci
allez tout ira bien
ce genre je regrette qu'il n'ait pas été
remarqué dans ce théâtre en tant que
danseur classique à aller dimitri payet
que fait qu'au pape et on va boire un
café d'accord je fais idra semble aimer
affaires et j'arrive je peux vous
demander un café s'il vous plaît bien
sûr dimitri nous avons fini notre
préparation
je suis en forme maintenant est ce pas
mon stage ont donc j'écoute ce n'est pas
notre dernier travaille ensemble
mais c'est notre dernier travaille dans
ce théâtre vous partez oui j'ai pris ma
décision
alors c'est décidé il faut aller de
l'avant sans graisser je m'y attendais
mais cela m'a vraiment perturbé ce que
j'espérais tout de même que constantin
resterait et que nous continuerions et a
travaillé dans ce théâtre
les voilà je suis arrivé chance pour le
concours en bourse et pour le reste on
verra plus tard
thakoon aux bestiaux baugé donné tant de
force au théâtre que je l'équité sans
autre emploi derrière coup d'arrêt
j'avais besoin d'un certain temps pour
calmer tout ce que j'avais à l'intérieur
de moi même je t'oublie avoir trouvé la
force nécessaire pour continuer à
exercer ma profession au préfet
c'est fini pour moi dans ce théâtre
je ne peux pas me développer d'un point
de vue créatif c'est pourquoi quand
constantin est parti je me suis rendu
compte que c'était le moment pour moi
aussi parce que je n'avais ni
enseignants dits répertoire j'ai décidé
de m'en aller aussi
et
[Musique]
oui
c'est pour ne pas se faire des ampoules
mais on s'en fait on savait tout de même
on peut pas l'éviter avec ou sans
attendre est oui alors attention
m
malheureusement constantin a quitté
notre théâtre dimitri qui était soliste
dans ce théâtre l'a quittée au 604 air
beaucoup de spectacle on était monté
spécialement pour lui participé à
presque tous les spectacles
je ne savais pas que dimitri allait
partir c'était totalement inattendu pour
moi
pourtant à sa manière de travailler ces
derniers temps à son attitude envers les
répétitions on pouvait s'attendre à son
départ nous avons dû chercher un
remplaçant en vitesse et avons réussi
les spectacle continue je vous mettons
en scène de nouveaux spectacles
le travail se poursuit pendant jeunes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
après tchoco tchoco temps je voudrais
danser les classiques wallonnes which we
had au nom oui c'est pourquoi je vais
probablement quitter le ballet de moscou
je pense que je resterai ici jusqu'à la
fin de cette saison
quant à la prochaine je n'en sais rien
[Musique]
la direction change et nous les
fonctionnaires du théâtre changeons avec
la direction
si quelqu'un n'aime pas l'orientation
définie par la direction
il peut tout à fait s'en aller personne
ne retient personne
[Musique]
oui